ein blick nur
ein augenblick
drei monate lang täglich sieben stunden
saß marina abramovic einfach nur da und
blickte über 1500 menschen in die augen
das new yorker museum of modern art
erlebt einen ansturm sondergleichen
die große marina abramovic retrospektive
die artist is present war für viele
besucher mehr als nur eine ausstellung
viele kräfte wollten beobachtet von
kameras und anderen besuchern den einen
besonderen moment erlebt
nach 7 136 stunden stand ich auf und
spürte dass ich nicht verändert hatte
etwas war anders geworden
ich fühlte einen großen drang etwas
sinnvolles in meinem leben zu schaffen
all meine erfahrung aus 40 jahren bevor
man es kunst weiter zu vererben
woraus das vermächtnis von marina
abramovic bestehen wird kann man nun in
basel im gehalten des museums erleben
dort steht ein zelt paris in dem jeweils
vier menschen auf eine reise durch
sieben räume geschickt werden man
schließt einen vertrag verpflichtet sich
zu zwei stunden selbsterfahrung und
trinkt zum beispiel wasser das durch
einen kristall gereinigt wurde
schluck für schluck in slow motion
im zweiten raum dann die begegnung mit
einem anderen besucher eine reminiszenz
an die artist is present
sie blicken jemandem in die augen sehen
sie noch nie gesehen denn sie noch nie
gesprochen
wir betreten damit einen raum außerhalb
der normalen realität
man beginnt darüber nachzudenken was ist
die bestimmung des lebens tun wir das
richtige ist man neugierig genug etwas
neues zu versuchen
das sind die fragen die stelle es ist
wie eine kur kultureller art die ich
hier vorschlagen um sich selbst zu
entdecken
zurück zur einfachheit zu finden es wäre
so einfach das alles hämisch lächerlich
zu machen als esoterischen anflug einer
alternden kunst iva die sich sorgen
macht um ihren platz in der
kunstgeschichte ihre arbeiten früher
waren verstörender
als sie mit der symbolik jugoslawiens
provozierte
die schmerzvolle körpererfahrung zur
kunstform erhob
das rollenspiel zwischen mann und frau
thematisiert sich großen gefahren
aussetzt
man muss dem tod ins auge sehen
eines tages werde ich gehen und nicht
mehr sein ich frage mich was wird mein
vermächtnis sein
wie kann ich meine erfahrungen
vertrauensvoll weitergeben an die
öffentlichkeit die davon profitieren
sollen benefit sie will ein institut
bauen den hudson in der nähe von new
york
die besucher sollen dort als erstes ihre
wahrnehmungsfähigkeit schärfen ihre
sensibilität ihre offenheit für kunst
erst danach sollen sie sich zeit nehmen
um kunst zu betrachten und zu erleben
performance musik oper
stararchitekt rem koolhaas hat es
entworfen
2015 soll es fertig sein der bestwert
das beste ist das system wird das
perpetuum mobile das ich geschaffen habe
das publikum wird selbst performen das
ganze kann ohne künstler funktionieren
ich bin sehr stolz auf diese erfindung
sie nimmt die profunde erfahrung ihrer
eigenen performance und will sie vielen
zugänglich machen
ein modell bauen einen raum in dem die
zeit stehen bleibt in dem nichts ist nur
die pure begegnung mit sich selbst mit
dem gegenüber und der kunst denke
darüber nach wie man das menschliche
bewusstsein verändert zurück zur
einfachheit weg von der komplizierten
historischen welt das wird all meine
zeit beanspruchen
aber das will ich versuchen